do you uh thinking thinking back to 2001
right you end up signing with cash money
putting out Banger ball
that's around like right before we get
like Peak Lil Wayne Like Superstar Wayne
I feel like was like oh 405 when he
dropped the first card is when that kind
of started but like were you around
Wayne back then yeah he was a kid like
like 14 15 years old or something when I
was around him yeah I feel like it's
crazy people don't even understand that
like back then like obviously juvie was
juvie but the big timers were the
biggest [__] on cash money out once
juvenile kind of like you know 400
Degrees came out and like I felt like
Soldier red came out or not Soldier rank
soldiers before that uh G-Code but uh
the Big Timers were [__] lit big
Thomas was good big Thomas was good but
but but but Junior was a special talent
like a like a a different kind of
[__] like he was I knew he was
incredible like when he was a kid I told
stunning there boy here gonna be the
business he gonna be the [__] for real
you guys had sessions together back then
and all that oh yeah yeah it was like a
family huh like I was around like around
around and we was all around each other
like for real real and you know Wang was
young but I could tell at a young age he
was going to be
probably the best ever
obviously Birdman is like one of the
most prolific CEOs ever we hear like
mixed things though when it comes like
signing with cash money there's people
who have complaints people who say it
went great your experience was great
I don't got nothing to say yeah you know
my experience was was was was was was
player it was a player situation I can't
do nothing but but but but have uh
you know love and respect for for him
and slim you know and all of the guys
that that I've met through them or you
know everybody associated with cash
money has been all Open Arms with me for
you know since the beginning for sure